[Music]
welcome back here to good day las vegas
metro sheriff joe lombardo joins us once
again for our morning cup of joe segment
sheriff good to see you once again
good morning john all right so let's
talk about something that's been
happening across the valley in the last
couple of weeks we've seen a spike in
homicides across the valley
quite simply why have we been seeing
this increase in violent
violent crime if you look at the stats
across the nation
there's been an overall 25 percent i
believe it's right around 25 percent
increase in homicides
here locally we've experienced around a
10 percent increase
so that is one positive thing but i
guess every
every homicide is is a negative thing so
to call it down or to evaluate our local
homicides we've had a significant
increase in domestic violence
homicides and perceived disrespect and
what
what that means is you know you're
you're at a party together
um your emotions get fueled and
what used to be a fight would elevate to
a homicide
unfortunately and we've had a 40 percent
42 percent
increase in that particular crime so
it's important that we do a thorough
investigation no matter who it is
whoever the victim is and get these
individuals
that are causing the problems in jail
to address their to answer for their
crimes uh let's talk about something
else a little bit here uh we've talked
also before about covet 19 and the
effect on the department we've uh we
know about
it's already hit close to home not only
for you personally but for the
department
in general what the coronavirus has done
what is the
latest on cases office or wellness
within in the department
we're averaging between five and ten
positive uh employees on a daily basis
um if you look at our total numbers
since the beginning of march we're right
around 460
positive employees so with my total
workforce if you did you did the math on
that it's around seven percent positive
um compared to the workforce so the
benchmark for the state and the county
is eight percent so we're below
that benchmark and which is important to
to evaluate because
we have a little more interaction with
the general public than most people do
and so it's not like we can work from
home
um in that vein so i think we're doing a
pretty good job
addressing it on a daily basis basis but
we have concerns in the back of my mind
personally that those numbers are going
to continue to increase
let's talk about another issue that is
not necessarily new to las vegas the
issue of sex trafficking metro's made
several arrests recently
in some sex trafficking cases is this an
issue that is growing and maybe sort of
resurging again once again in southern
nevada
here in clark county it's it's no
different than anywhere else that you
may experience and
would think it would be different
because of the tourism environment but
that's not the case um
i think we have a pretty good handle on
on
that particular issue we have some
pretty robust investigations
going on with that issue but for for to
be described as increasing i would not
describe it that way
uh thank you very much sheriff for
joining us here on good day las vegas if
you at home have a question for sheriff
joe lombardo
you can submit it at eightnewsnow.com
find out if your question is answered
every wednesday